der kürzeste hits meine damen und herren
lautete früher gehen zwei studenten an
einer kneipe vorbei heute lautet der
kürzeste witz schaut jemand in der
gegend herum
ehrlich gesagt finde ich es nicht witzig
dass das heute ein witz sein soll
vielmehr finde ich es bedauerlich dass
wir alle nur noch so auf einer bank
sitzen
statt einfach mal den blick schweifen zu
lassen genau diese kulturpessimistischen
klagen kann mein heutiger gast nicht
mehr hören
bei mir ist roberto simanowski professor
für digitale medien und der experte wenn
es um die philosophische
auseinandersetzung mit facebook geht er
sagt natürlich ist facebook
zeitverschwendung natürlich macht uns
das netzwerk zu gläsernen bürgern
natürlich sind wir gefangen im filter
lassen aber die sozialen medien sind
interessanter aus dass ich bin mal
gespannt herzlich willkommen
guten morgen frau wolski ich bin genauso
einige sie beschreiben ich finde es
eigentlich eher bedauerlich und
befremdlich wie viel zeit wir mit
unseren smartphones verbringen im
sekundentakt whatsup messages checken um
mehr zeit aufwenden dafür dass facebook
profil zu pflegen als unsere waren
freundschaften wie denken sie darüber
mir geht es da wie ihnen
ich versuche ein überlanges zu finden
natürlich muss ich mich mit den sozialen
medien muss sich auf den sozialen medien
vertreten sein wenn ich mich damit
beschäftige
aber wenn sie meinen facebook profil
anschauen das ist nicht sehr gepflegt
und und das mit gründen auch aus
ideologischen gründen oder aus
machtpolitischen gründen weil ich nicht
so viele daten über mich her geben will
aber auch weil ich zu viel zeit brauchen
die realen kontakte mit meinen freunden
zu zeigen aber gleichzeitig sagen sie am
anfang ihres neuesten buches facebook
gesellschaft sehr deutlich sie sind
diese klagen leid
ja ich bin sie leid weil man mit klagen
natürlich niemanden erreicht also wenn
man man kann
sich nur begrenzt über neue medien und
die damit verbundenen kulturformen
beklagen erreicht damit aber niemanden
zuhörer
er wird man sich damit mit verständnis
oder mit interesse für diese dinge und
ich denke da an meine mutter die als ich
16 war sich über meine langen haare
meiner ausgewaschenen jeans und die
laute musik beschwert und damit
überhaupt nicht erreicht mit mir ins
gespräch zu kommen
aber ins gespräch kommen muss man und
dann muss man auch mal die jeans selber
anziehen oder die laute musik sich antun
ja das waren wir heute mal tun
interessant ist jetzt was ihn bei spiel
gebracht haben was er genau aufzeigt
dass wir oftmals einfach genau das eben
wie als befremdlich bewerten was wir
nicht kennen und viele sagen ja auch na
ja heute haben die die smartphones für
uns aber früher haben die leute in der
traum einfach zeitung gelesen was genau
ist eigentlich der unterschied den wir
uns vorstellen dass ich alle dahinter
ihren zeitungs blättern versteckt haben
ja neben dem medium das ein anderes ist
ist es die anzahl und der inhalt würde
ich sagen es waren eben wenigere die das
früher gemacht haben und wahrscheinlich
waren war ein grossteil davon getrieben
von dem wunsch sich und die welt besser
zu verstehen der eben dazu führte dass
man jegliche minute die man frei hatte
nutzen wollte und das ist heute nicht
unbedingt gegeben
heute würde ich fast sagen ist das
umgedrehte der fall dass diejenigen die
nichts an ihrem smartphone sind
vielleicht kontemplativ unterwegs sind
nachdenken über etwas über sich und die
welt während diejenigen die in
smartphones schauen sich ja in diesen
kommunikations dieses kommunikations
karussell gegeben dass sie beschäftigt
eltern vorurteile so ist kann ja auch
sein dass die leute zum beispiel auf dem
smartphone sternstunde gucken
ich bin mir ganz sicher dass viele das
tun werden
ich bin mir auch sicher dass so vielen
smartphones er
ein verletzung texte nzz zu finden ist
und das wäre dann natürlich einen
vorteil gegenüber der bild zeitung die
man in den händen hält
wie vor einigen jahren etwa ich glaube
es aber nicht nach und nicht weil zum
einen weil ich den leuten über die
schulter sehen und wir stehen ja dicht
gedrängt in der u-bahn in hongkong und
dann sehe ich was da drauf ist und das
ist größtenteils sind dass
computerspiele oder filme die
sternstunden waren noch nicht dabei
derzeit kommen und und vor allen dingen
dann kommunikation und gegen
kommunikation also whatsapp oder was
auch immer man benutzt dafür way
kommunikation mit den anderen oder eben
man schaut sich an die updates auf den
sozialen netzwerken was da mit den
freunden so passiert ist
und da ging es eigentlich nicht zu sagen
sie haben gerade schon erwähnt sie leben
in hongkong sie haben nur eine professur
in hongkong für digitale medien sie
haben kürzlich gerade einen artikel
geschrieben in dem sie auch so ein
bisschen beschreiben den zombie den
smartphone zombie in hongkong sie
schreiben darin dass jeder zweite
mittlerweile mit dem smartphone vor den
augen durch die straßen geht dass es
entsprechende schilder gibt in hongkong
da steht nicht drauf meint beachtung
stufe sondern hatten sie sich auch mal
fester zwischen schauen sie dass sie
nicht ineinander prallen wenn sie ihr
smartphone lesen während den sie
herumgehen sind die unterschiede für sie
jetzt ein im straßenbild massiv wenn sie
in europa sind im vergleich zu hongkong
ich glaube europa ist beim aufholen also
es gibt jetzt auch hier genug die mit
dem smartphone in der hand und ambiente
tänzen wie man das zu schönen
durch die straßen zu kommen versuchen
der unterschied wäre der das
nirgendwo so viele menschen auf so engen
fußwegen unterwegs sind wie in hongkong
und man eigentlich dort sich das gar
nicht leisten könnte dabei dann auf
smartphone zu schauen und das trägt dann
schon zu ein bisschen zu einem ärger bei
weil man dann ja immer selbst gezwungen
ist den anderen aus dem weg zu gehen
auf dem auf dem buch facebook
gesellschaft hier nächstes nie vor
letztes buch facebook gesellschaft da
gibt es eine suppenschüssel mit einem
handy drauf da kann man also suppe essen
gleichzeitig ein smartphone gucken
jünger werden wir auch irgendwann in
europa solche suppenschüssel haben also
sobald ein produkt marktfähig wird und
das wird sie von einer die seiner firma
in taipeh in taiwan hergestellt haben
sich wohl neue kulturformen verfestigt
und das ist diese diese anti lang rahmen
bowl gibt wo man das handy gleich
befestigen kann zeigt dass wir einen
punkt erreicht haben an dem selbst in
asien immerhin die kultur des
despotismus selbst dort nicht mehr das
essen von anderen formen der aktivität
getrennt wird und ich weiß nicht ob wir
den punkt auch erreichen werden es ist
eigentlich eher in eine ein gadget 1 1
ein gewiss objekt aber ich würde mich
nicht wundern wenn wir bald da hinkommen
ich sehe auch hier in europa viele
menschen die während des essens auch
dass das handy dabei haben und schon
diese dinge nicht drin
es ist ja auch so dass man sich dem so
unglaublich schlecht entziehen kann ich
stelle das an mir selber fest wenn ich
irgendwo eine ecke warte auf die
straßenbahn beispielsweise ist der griff
in die taschen zum handy hin unglaublich
schnell vollzogen
und ich merke jeweils dass sich die
glücklicheren tage verbringe wenn ich
meine leistung einpacker stadt mein
iphone ein stück granit ein kunstobjekt
des bildhauers horst bohne
er hat das gemacht das ist einfach ein
stück granit polierter granit ständig
geladen ständig auf stumm gestellt für
echte kontakte bleibt noch möglichkeit
genug warum macht es mich glücklicher
ohne mein iphone unterwegs zu sein warum
nehme ich dann trotzdem trotzdem mit ja
weil wir uns dieser versuchung immer in
die kommunikation oder in eine
zerstreuung zu entfliehen nicht
entziehen können und es ist schon in der
tat
paradox und absurd dass wir dann solche
kunstobjekte brauchen die uns davon
abhalten normalerweise ist kommen diese
guten momente im leben wenn die batterie
gestorben ist oder wenn wir kein empfang
an
das sind die momente wo wir nicht
entfliehen können oder dass das
technische gerät uns verlässt und wir
wieder auf uns zurück verwiesen sind das
sind nicht gut im moment diese wären
nicht als gute momente erfahren in dem
moment sondern eher als belastung und
als druck aber meiner perspektive sind
es die guten momente war
man in diesen momenten noch zu sich
selbst kommt was sie dazu kann ich in
ein beispiel geben in asien
schafft man sich künstlich momente des
künstlich momente in denen die
smartphones uns nicht regieren in soul
gab es im letzten jahr im mai ein so
eine art wettbewerb in einem in einem
park haben sich 60 personen getroffen
und 90 minuten lang da gesessen ohne ein
smartphone und das war die kunstaktion
das war die kunstaktion die durften auch
nicht miteinander sprechen wir mussten
einfach da sie zu 90 minuten lang nichts
tun und sieger war derjenige dessen puls
am längsten sehr lauf- lofer sehr
niedrig war
interessanterweise hat dann ein
bekannter 28 jährige rapper gewonnen der
gerade eine platte einspielte und mental
und physisch so erschöpft war das wie
möglich aber man muss sich das überlegen
da haben 1500 leute sich beworben um
diese 60 plätze im park jeder kann in
einen park gehen und einfach 90 minuten
in die gegend schauen gut da wie zwar
vielleicht auch noch was man teil eines
kunstprojektes sein konnte deswegen ist
das ja auch attraktiv wann hat ein
kunstobjekt bei sich und nicht einfach
nichts weiß ich wir sind ja doch
irgendwie so taktil unterwegs dass wir
dauernd in ihren fingern müssen das kann
man damit ja auch nun soziale medien
bergen ein suchtpotenzial das haben sie
jetzt gerade auch gesagt nicht nur
facebook sondern ganz viele verschiedene
soziale medien denken ganz netter und
tumbler twitter und so weiter wir
sprechen heute schwerpunktmäßig über
facebook es ist nach wie vor das größte
soziale netzwerk in der schweiz sind 3,9
millionen personen aktiv auf facebook
tendenz interessanterweise wieder
steigend in der schweiz und wir haben
passantinnen und passanten gefragt ob
sie sich selber für suchtgefährdet
halten mit blick auf facebook
vorweg und dann nur noch ein video
slogan nun haben es auch postalisch das
ist ja so vieles was die anderen machen
suchtpotenzial ich sehe natürlich viele
selbstdarsteller die unterwegs sind
wahrscheinlich nicht nur auf facebook
insofern besteht vielleicht die gefahren
dieser ganzen elfi atmosphäre dass man
tatsächlich zu viel wert darauf legt wie
wirklich nach außen und ich nutze dann
eben facebook als plattform um das
darzustellen also ich und auch unter
vielen kollegen ist es so man öffentlich
safari oder so und dann ist der erste
schriftliche schritt erst mal facebook
oder man system arbeiten und dann macht
man zwar ist man schon wieder auf
facebook am scrollen ohne dass man es
unbedingt eigentlich braucht ja ich
glaube es macht schon süchtig ja ja sie
mal auf die sind ja selber auf facebook
sind aber haben sie vorhin gesagt gar
nicht so oft aktiv da ich bin nicht oft
genug da um mit den updates seiner
facebook freunde auf dem laufenden zu
bleiben das stimmt aber ich bin oft
genug da um zu wissen wie facebook
funktioniert und um auch diese sucht
dieses suchtpotenzial diese suchtgefahr
erfahren zu haben von der hier
gesprochen wurde und der ich mich dann
gerne selbst proaktiv entziehen indem
ich eben facebook nicht jeden tag öffnen
und auch gar nicht auf dem smartphone wo
die meisten jetzt auf facebook gehen
sondern nur auf dem laptop um nicht
zuviel zeit mit all den interessanten
dingen zu verbringen die ich ja dann
doch finde weil ich natürlich
interessante freunde habe die dann auch
interessante links zu interessanten
videos oder artikeln
posten und denen ich dann folge und wie
sich merkel das schon zwei stunden
vergangen sind und ich doch eigentlich
schon längst beim arbeiten seien wollte
dann zwingt mich deswegen zwingt mich
für digitale medien zu ihrer arbeit ist
auch üblich fest ja da haben sie schon
recht haben scheint aber meine
preußische disziplin sagt mir dann auch
das dass ich das nicht so lange machen
darf und sonst wenig zu lang auf
facebook bin komme ich nicht dazu ein
buch über facebook zu schreiben zunächst
und sie schreiben ja eben bücher und
wenn ich ihr buch lese dann merke ich
auch sie lesen auch sehr viele bücher
sie sind eigentlich so ein typischer
intellektueller und elektro sehr belesen
halten sich selber für einen
kulturpessimisten nein nein dazu bin ich
ja zu belesen also als mit einem
gewissen verständnis weiß man ja dass es
den kulturpessimismus zeit der
griechischen antike gibt basiert kommt
es vor die klage über den verlust des
goldenen zeitalters und und die welt ist
trotzdem immer weiter gegangen
das ist man dachte youtube pessimismus
sagte dass alles zugrunde geht
die jetzige und die künftige entwicklung
und wir wissen dass es immer weiter ging
und selbst aus unserer generation und
ich weiß meine die generation meiner
eltern und großeltern hat auch auf uns
auf unsere kulturellen gepflogenheiten
mit skepsis und pessimismus geschaut
selbst aus unserer generation ist ja
etwas geworden wenn ich das jetzt mal so
behaupten und dann wäre es vermessen zu
sagen die millennials das aus dem wird
und gar nichts mehr weil die nun ganz
andere formen des des miteinander
umgehens haben die wir gar nicht mehr
verstehen
also da denke ich gut ist
kulturpessimismus nichts was
intellektuelle als perspektive anstreben
sollten
es sei denn sie sind sehr alt und
brauchen es als sterbehilfe ist ja da
ist ja auch ein bisschen immer einfach
ist gut dass man sowieso nicht belassen
nicht mehr erleben muss nach dem motto
es geht alles den bach hinunter nein das
dass es das ist unsinn was ich würde
mich eher als kulturkritiker bezeichnung
vielleicht auch als romantiker denn es
gibt bestimmte kulturelle formen des des
kommunizierens oder dass der des
miteinander umgehens die ich mag und an
denen ich gerne festhalten würde ja zb
dass man das smartphone eben nicht in
die suppenschüssel eingibt oder auch
nicht einmal mitbringt in die kneipe
schaut man sich wenn man sich mit
freunden trifft wo dann die smartphones
auf dem tisch ja sowie pistolen wie die
waffen liegen mit denen man dem den das
gegenüber jederzeit bei jedem anruf der
kommt ins kommunikative aus schießen
kann
das wäre für mich eine sache wurden an
zur sache wäre vielleicht auch dass man
den tag nicht damit beendet auf
smartphone zu schauen sondern auf die
freundin den partnern
das ist ein schönes bild für romantik
gebe ich zu ein einweg mit
kulturpessimismus umzugehen und
vielleicht eben vielleicht ein
kulturkritiker zu werden oder zum kultur
beobachter ist auf jeden fall nicht
sofort zu bewerten sondern eben erst
einmal zu beobachten
ich selber war nicht auf facebook bis
vor ganz kurzem vor wenigen tagen habe
ich ein profil erstellt weil ich mir
auch gesagt habe man kann nicht dauernd
nur kritisch darauf blicken man muss
auch mal mitmachen
ich war bis anhin nur auf twitter jetzt
möchte ich da einsteigen um mir das auch
genauer anzusehen und ich möchte dieses
gesprächen nehmen auch nutzen und besser
zu verstehen worum geht es denn
eigentlich also bevor wir bewerten mal
und die sache genauer anzuschauen
etwas was ihm auffällt und was oft eben
mit kritik auch verbunden wird ist
dieses dauernde posten also leute
pausieren vize-posten urlaubsbilder sie
posten das was sie essen sie sagen das
hat gar nicht so viel zu tun mit
narzissmus wie wir meinen sondern ist
eigentlich was anderes was steckt
dahinter
ja auf den ersten blick ist es natürlich
diese ganze selbstdarstellung ist sieht
natürlich sehr nach nazismus aus und
nach eitelkeit
auf den zweiten blick für den ich in
diesem buch werbe kann man darin aber
auch ein ausdruck des leidens und sogar
der solidarität erkennen und das mag
jetzt nicht gleich verständlich sein
deswegen brauche ich im buch auch einige
seiten einige unterkapitel um das
argumentative zu untermauern
vielleicht hier nur zwei der hinweis auf
zwei personen im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
die dieses problem bereits behandelten
denn es geht darum wie man mit dem was
man erlebt umgeht und dann gibt es ein
schön kurzen essay von walter benjamin
aus den 30er jahren erfahrung und armut
wo er die innerliche verarmung der des
modernen menschen beschreibt der eben
nicht mehr die dinge erfährt sondern nur
noch erlebt also ohne verinnerlichung
dessen was er erlebt auf einer
oberflächlichen weise und erzählt dann
natürlich auch auf die touristen die ja
wie wir es heute auch kennen die dinge
sehr oberflächlich den dingen sehr
oberflächlich begegnen und interessant
ist dass benjamin dann sagt das das
andenken dass man also damals schon
mitbringen konnte bevor es museumsshops
gab es wie sie wie es sie heute überall
gibt das das andenken eine art ist
einigermaßen anständig aus dieser
situation herauszukommen
lassen sie mich ganz kurz ein beispiel
vielleicht mit ihnen erläutern wir auch
nicht vor nach paris ich sehe den
eiffelturm was heißt jetzt den
eiffelturm erfahren und was heißt es in
alfeld uhr zu erleben und was mache ich
wenn ich in souvenirkauf gemäss walter
benjamin
also lassen sie mich noch den anderen
die andere position mit einbringen denn
das wäre die antwort darauf dass agenten
der in einem an msc der italienische
philosoph kindheit und geschichte 1978
dhabi da sagt er dass die meisten und es
zieht auf touristen genau auf der
touristen in etwa vor dem eiffelturm
dass die meisten im angesichts der
wunder der welt es vorziehen die kamera
erleben zu lassen
das heißt man macht ein foto und geht
dann weiter oder man kauft sich
vielleicht noch den eiffelturm hat ihn
dann zu hause stehen
aber man ist vielleicht nicht
hochgegangen man hat gar keinen oder gar
nicht viel zeit verbracht auf dem
eiffelturm mit dem eiffelturm
man hat ihn nicht als objekt wirklich
erfahren man hat den raum gar nicht auf
den eiffelturm erleben heißt hoch zu
kraxeln den schwindel zu erleben an
zustehenden ticket zu kaufen dieses
ganze setting sozusagen ich da rein zu
begeben
ich möchte so lange darüber nachdenken
was zu den eiffelturm direkt heißt aber
ich kann ihnen sagen wenn sie in paris
für anders hingehen ins ins louvre und
dann vor der mona lisa stehen dann
gehört dazu wenn es überhaupt noch
möglich ist
vor der mona lisa ein bisschen länger zu
stehen und die die sich dem blick
auszusetzen der auf so viele zuschauer
geblickt hat benjamin and dass die aua
dass man vor dem objekt noch steht das
machen die meisten aber nicht die nehmen
sich ein foto völlig sendung war es
diese fotos jahr am mars gibt und viel
besser und gehen dann wieder davon also
das ist kein erleben das ist kein
wirklicher
verbundenheit mit dem mit dem
kunstobjekt in diesem moment man muss da
schon länger davor stehen was man bei
der mona lisa war ohnehin nicht tun kann
weil der raum gefüllt ist mit
fotografierenden aber das ist das was
erkannten meint und seine aussage dass
man dann faktisch dass das erleben
delegiert an die kamera hat zwei
implikationen zu machen dass man es dass
man dann eben das fotografierte nicht
erlebt und zum anderen dass dieses
erleben auch später nicht passiert wenn
man das foto anschauen könnte das mag zu
stimmen für ganze zeit auf jeden fall
ist es radikaler jetzt der fall wenn man
nicht mehr durch digitale technik auf
wenige fotos angewiesen ist also sich
nicht einmal mehr fragen muss welches
wäre denn das jetzt das richtige foto in
diesem moment und das ist ja schon eine
auseinandersetzung mit dem objekt das
müssen sie heute gar nicht mehr machen
sie sehen leute die in einem raum zehn
fotos machen ja in einen museumsraum
oder in einer nacht mit der kamera
musste man fragen die einstellungen
suchen das licht und vor allen dingen
sind sie dann hin und her gegangen haben
geschaut was ist denn jetzt
repräsentativ für diesen ort denn sie
konnten das war ja auch eine ökonomische
frage und es gab ja auch nur 24 oder 36
will auf dem film sie konnten gar nicht
so viel fotografieren
diese sachen diese beschränkungen gibt
es mit der digitalen technologie nicht
mehr und sie können also sofort sehr
viele fotos machen und sie können auch
sofort diese fotos dann teilen und das
ist der andere punkt es gab früher
sicherlich dann noch den dia abend an
dem man das fotografierte anderen
geschildert hat und sicherlich auch
gewissermaßen nachträglich in eine in
einen narrativen ordnung gebracht
ich habe ein altes album mitgebracht aus
meiner eigenen kindheit von meinem vater
schön sortiert so sagen die augen ja
früher aus man hat die da eingeklebt und
dann steht dann sozusagen eine
geschichte eine biografie band 1 meines
lebens da geht's am ende mehr
mittlerweile das hat man heute nicht
mehr
sie sind da das dach das kommt dazu sie
haben das foto sie haben sich gefragt
welches foto ist jetzt wichtig dann
haben sie die fotos eingeklebt haben
sich ein text ausgedacht dazu und in
diesem moment erfährt man dann doch
wieder das was man vielleicht mit der
kamera hinter der kamera nicht so
wahrgenommen hat diagrammen sagt aber
heute sind sie ja schon an dem ort an
dem sie das foto herstellen abgekoppelt
von dem ort denn sie haben es ja sofort
auf facebook oder instagram gesetzt oder
über snapshot geteilt und warten jetzt
auf die reaktionen ihrer freundin aus
dem sozialen netzwerk und also sie das
sind die leute die sie dann im museum in
einer ecke sitzen sehen an ihrem handy
die dies sozusagen darüber das berichten
was sie gerade erleben beziehungsweise
eben nicht wirklich erleben
genau um diese these ist das erleben
wird sozusagen dünner und sie sagen aber
auch dahinter verbirgt sich so etwas wie
eine gegenwart flucht wovor fliehen wir
denn da naja es ist dieser es ist es ist
die ohnmacht vor diesen wundern der welt
dass wir eigentlich nicht wissen was wir
mit ihnen tun sollen
das wäre eigentlich der anforderungen
die von von einem kunstwerk im besten
fall ausgehen und in einem im extremfall
heißt es immer sie wissen
rilkes gedicht über über das kunstobjekt
archaischer torso apollos da es keine
stelle die dich nicht sieht du musst
dein leben ändern lassen natürlich
extrem aussagen von künstlern aber ein
bisschen ist das immer es gibt also der
volks spruch dafür wäre venedig sehen
und sterben
danach gibt es nichts mehr aber nein wir
sind in venedig und wir sterben dazu
will ich nicht eher überlegen wir was
wir zu abend essen werden und diese
diese banalisierung dessen was wir
erleben oder diese unfähigkeit dieser
wucht der der wunder der welt ja gesagt
innerlich zu entsprechen das ist das was
uns in diesem fall in diesem moment und
ein gewisses gefühl das verlorensein
vermittelt und da kommt jetzt die
solidarität mit hinein
wir teilen das dann mit unseren freunden
auf den sozialen netzwerken die uns eine
bestätigung durch ihre leid für das
geben was wir gerade erfahren obwohl wir
gar nicht so richtig erfahren wir wissen
gar nicht was wir nun fühlen sollen vor
der mona lisa
ja aber sie kriegen dann viele likes
dafür dass auch sie die mona lisa
gesehen haben fotografiert haben das
bewiesen haben jetzt und das ist das ist
faktisch die soll das solidarische an
diesen an dieser selbstdarstellung
deswegen ist es nicht nur eitelkeit
sondern es ist auch ein ein umgehen mit
mit dem leiden dass wir in diesen
momenten erfahren und wir fliehen dann
faktisch in das gruppenkuscheln der
likes auf den sozialen netzwerken
gruppenkuscheln lassen lassen sie nicht
kurz noch versuchen die sache zu wenden
man könnte doch auch sagen so aller
geteilte freude ist doppelte freut wir
teilen die bilder und der moment
steigert sich es ist nicht dieses diese
unfähigkeit nicht zu erleben sondern im
gegenteil das erleben es wird noch
größer dadurch dass ich sagen kann leute
guckt mal wie ihre dieser
sonnenuntergang hier gerade ist ja das
ist möglich
ich würde aber man muss man muss sich ja
immer fragen in welchem kontext werden
diese dinge dann wahrgenommen
also zum einen kann es sein dass der
sonnenuntergang auch schon ausdruck
einer hilflosigkeit ist dass man sieht
den sonnenuntergang oder einen
regenbogen und statt ihn zu genießen
statt in erfurt dazu stehen nimmt man
ihn auf und geht weiter dann hat man
dieses bild so wie wird das bild jetzt
angeschaut das bild wird ja dann
irgendwann in der u-bahn oder im
fahrstuhl zwischen zwei stationen sieht
man mal kurz das smartphone heraus und
schaut was was schaut sich die updates
der freunde an und da gibt es dann 10 50
bilder die man in diesem moment anschaut
und da gibt man schnell ein like oder
nicht und geht weiter also das ist im
seltensten fall nehme ich an
verursacht ein solches bild dann
wirklich eine eine solche ein solches
teilen auch der stimmung die vielleicht
nicht einmal ursprünglich erfahren wurde
wie sie das vermuten
ich habe in ihrem buch auch gelesen dass
sie sagen diese gegenwart flucht die
treten wir auch deswegen an weil die
metaphysische obdachlos sind
was genau meint damit das ist nah dass
jetzt da wird es dann natürlich
geschichtsphilosophische das ist sein da
beziehe ich mich auftrag aber siegfried
kracauer viele theoretiker film
theoretiker zeitgenosse von benjamin
freund von adorno und ja gehört auch so
ein bisschen mit so zum vorfeld der
kritischen theorie und und der
medientheorie und er sagt es in einem
kapitel in den angestellten das 1930
erschienen ist dass das moderne subjekt
sich heimatlos fühlten floss im
metaphysischen sinne das weiß nicht mehr
wo fürs lebt und wohin es unterwegs ist
er nimmt ausdrücklich die organisierten
arbeiter aus davon denn die haben ja
eine klassenkampf auf die lagen die
lions sind die haben ja eine sozusagen
eine der sie folgen und ost vor der im
hintergrund ihr individuelles leben
danach eine bedeutung hat und eine eine
wucht gewinn aber die anderen die das
nicht haben
und die sich auch befreit haben von
anderen großen erzählungen also frei
time aus der christlichen erzählung etwa
dass man darauf hin lebt auf der auf ein
jenseits oder dergleichen
die haben diese heimat nicht mehr und
für die wird dann sorgt dann die
zerstreuung industrie verschwörungs
kultur oder was er dort dann später die
kulturindustrie nennt und was krakau
schon sehr schön beschreibt also die
lichtspielhäuser die restaurants und so
weiter
interessanterweise sagte dann auch dass
die lichtspielhäuser oder die häuser des
lichts auf die restaurants das sind die
orte der dunkelheit und das spielt
natürlich mit der licht metapher der
aufklärung weil an diesen orten eben
gerade nicht das nachdenken über sich
und die welt passiert sondern ablenkung
und zerstreuung und jetzt habe ich den
faden verloren was herr ausgangspunkt
der frage war aber ich fragte sie nach
der metaphysischen obdachlosigkeit weil
sie sagen mit verweis auf krakauer dass
wir heute ebenso eine metaphysische
obdachlosigkeit gesteigert sogar
empfinden weil diese angebote nicht mehr
da sind und das auch zu tun mit facebook
samt inzwischen gibt es nach krakau gibt
es ja sogar offizielle erklärungen zum
ende der geschichte fukuyama 1989
erklärt die liberale marktwirtschaft als
den sieger der geschichte ja ich die
garantiert aber das diskutieren wir
heute nicht das ist die da das wäre eine
längere debatte absichten jahren gehört
hat aber es ist der punkt war dass wir
nicht nur unterwegs sind zu
da ist die utopie einer einer befreiten
aus bildungs ausbildungs losen
gesellschaft wie sie der marxismus
theoretisch anbot und unternahm und wie
sie dann im realsozialistischen des
sozialismus in den ende sogar den jungen
und den ostblock staaten unternommen
wurde dass diese utopie versagt hat dem
oder disqualifiziert war und alleine
anderes problem des notars erklärung zum
ende der großen erzählungen also auch
die sprachkritik der postmoderne die er
mit hinein fiel mit hinein führt das
alles lässt uns sehr relativ in unserem
leben sein und macht es schwer die
gegenwart noch als etwas zu verstehen
dass der vergangenheit eine bessere
zukunft schuldig ist und ohne das sind
wir aber verloren
geschichtsphilosophische sehen in
unseren augen blicken und so leben wir
auch von augenblick zu augenblick das
ist die metaphysische obdachlosigkeit
sie sich da noch gestärkt hat und das
wird von vielen soziologen ja auch so
beschrieben nach der kürzlich
verstorbene sekunde baumann
der hat das liquid modernity genannte
also dass wir wichtige modernen wichtig
sind und hat gesagt ist es dass die
symbolik des dass der modernen identität
oder der identität des modernen menschen
von pilger sich gewandelt hat zum
touristen ja wir sind nicht nur
unterwegs zu irgendetwas hin sondern wir
sind wie touristen mal da mal da mal da
aber es fühlt sich nicht zusammen zu
einer geschichte ja es sind episoden die
für sich bleiben und das ist das problem
wo dann facebook und andere soziale
netzwerke die uns eben erlauben in
diesen momenten die sich nicht zu
irgendetwas zusammen zusammenfügen dann
aber doch eine art bestätigung durch die
soziale kommunikation mit anderen zu
bekommen und die wirkt eben stärker als
die von agenten beschriebener
delegierung des erlebens an eine
maschine an die kamera
das ist das wo diese sozialen netzwerke
uns dann helfen mit der gegenwart zu
recht zu kommen
da fällt mir hans ulrich gumbrecht da in
dem sie ja auch zitieren in ihrem buch
den literaturwissenschaftler in stanford
lehrte war kürzlich auch in den
sternstunden zu gast als es um die wahl
von donald trump ging und haben sich um
recht spricht er von der präsenzkultur
und er sagt wir leben heute einfach in
einer zeit in der die präsenzkultur groß
geworden ist und diesen kultur ablöst
man könnte auch sagen wir haben jetzt
nicht mehr weltverständnis sondern wir
haben welt umarmung oder miss
eingefahren man könnte es auch so wenn
das man sagt der sozusagen wahlspruch
der aufklärung waage zu wissen sagte er
heißt heute einfach waage zu umarmen
das muss ja per se immer noch nicht
schlecht sein das ist eine andere form
sich auf die welt zu beziehen nicht
verstehen sondern namens floating ja ja
ja es ist auch eine eine sache so diese
diese gedankenwelt umarmung team finden
sie ja auch am anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts bei rilke ganz stark ist
auch eine reaktion auf die moderne schon
an an deren in deren anfang
und man könnte bis zur romantik zurück
gehen also dass man diese momente stark
empfindet und fühlt und in und da kann
man auch nichts wenn man es so versteht
da kann man auch nichts gegen gumprecht
vorschlag von einer sinn kultur seine
präsenzkultur überzugehen sagen
problematisch wird es wenn man das als
theoretisch aufbaut als ein neues
verständnis modell für die gesellschaft
also wenn man dafür wirbt die freiheit
die frage nach dem sinn eben nicht mehr
zu stellen weil wir in der in der in
dieser frage nach dem was etwas bedeutet
und nicht nur was ist die welt erst
wirklich verstehen und sie auch und auch
die möglichkeit haben sie zu verändern
dann und das ist genau der punkt den
gumbrecht anspricht in hat er diesen
gedanken zeit den 80er jahren entwickelt
sein buch zur materialität der
kommunikation
aber dann 2004 war es glaube ich in
seinem buch präsenzkultur das auch sehr
persönlich zum teil ist beschreibt er
sein ungenügen oder seien seien
ungenügend mit dieser mit der forderung
immer sich selbst zu verbessern und die
welt zu verbessern
diese forderung die aus den 60er jahren
aus der kritischen theorie stand die
davon ausgeht dass wir das die
geschichte noch gar nicht begonnen hat
weil der mensch noch gar nicht auf dem
weg zur selbst befreiung und
emanzipation ist und und der sagt dass
eben das bringt es dort in den
zusammenhang dass man genau dass
deswegen will man die welt immer
verstehen weil man sie dann verändern
will und das will aber nicht mehr diesen
diesen zwang diesen imperativ weder sich
entziehen und das wollen übrigens viele
andere auch und das kann man auch
verstehen gerade vor dem hintergrund
eben des endes der großen erzählungen
und dass der problematik dass es das
soziale utopien nicht mehr funktionieren
wie früheren dass sie nicht mehr
glaubhaft sind und man auch weiß wie
viel unheil die realisierung solcher
utopien dann in der geschichte gebracht
hat da ist dann die umarmung dessen was
ist vielleicht die bessere alternative
aber das was wir sehen in sozialen
netzwerken ist etwas anders das ist
keine intensive umarmung dessen was ist
sondern eben eine flucht davon warum ein
beispiel vielleicht um die medien noch
mal einzubringen wenn sie ein wenn sie
das was sie erleben einfach beschreiben
nicht werten auch nicht vielleicht auch
gar nicht nach dem sinn fragen sondern
einfach beschreiben was ihnen passiert
dann passiert geschieht hat eine
intensivierung des erlebten ja und sie
verbinden sich mit dem was ist weil es
durch ihren kopf wenn sie es beschreiben
also so was wie ich bin in der traum es
ist karlshorst ich das dann poste ich
als nächstes was ich esse
danach baust dich
was aus der sitzung naja aber der
unterschied ist der wenn sie es posten
was sie essen dann ist der unterschied
geben welches medium sie benutzten ob
die schrift oder die fotografie werden
sie das fotografieren dann müssen sie
eben nur abbilden das ist eine
mechanische reproduktion des islams und
das garantiert noch nicht an ein
tieferes verständnis dessen was sie
erleben sie plädieren für die sprache
die sprachliche umsetzung schafft
distanz und verständnis ja ich sage
nicht dass wir keine fotos machen sollen
ja also es sind das wären vielleicht
auch andere alternative witzige formen
denkbar also dass sie zum beispiel
beschreibt es in dem neuen buch das sie
dass wir an einem tag an dem wir kein
foto keine fotos posten an dem ihr kein
foto posten können auf unserer auf
unserer facebook seite so wie es ja kein
no internet day gibt und no consumption
damit wir einmal einfach mal das
unterbrechen sowie darunter die
unterbrechung geschieht werden die
batterie versagt und wir plötzlich
wieder für eine halbe stunde um
abgelenkt sind mit uns und vielleicht
ist wer das ganz sinnvoll einen solchen
nur foto tag einzuführen
an dem wir dann das was wir erlebt haben
beschreiben müssen
es gibt es übrigens auch als
kunstprojekt das ist die picture
altötting wo jemand dann und dann damit
anfing das was er nicht fotografieren
konnte weil er in äthiopien war und dort
nicht so die kamera auf die menschen
halten konnte dann hatte das beschrieben
und das wurde dann zu einem projekt
einen weblog an dem auch viele andere
teilgenommen haben und einfach um
einfach dinge zu beschreiben die sie
erfahren haben oder vielleicht auch
nicht dass es gar nicht der punkt der
punkt ist aber dass man etwas beschreibt
und es da mit einem bewusst wird und das
haben sie nicht das ist nicht gegeben
wenn sie ein foto machen ich bin der
meinung dass viele die
viele fotos posten per tag am abend gar
nicht mehr wissen was überhaupt gepostet
haben ja darf ich sie so zuspitzen dass
ich sagen würde wir sehen mehr wenn wir
kein bild machen
ja und da würden sie auch eigentlich
wieder an krakauer anschließen der das
in einem anderen text über die
fotografie ein sw von 1927 beschreibt
das dass die fotografie eigentlich ein
anti erkenntnis mittel ist weil es uns
eben nicht zwingt die dinge die wichtig
sind zu beschreiben sondern weil und das
ist ja so dass beim schreiben oder auch
bei der malerei das was bedeutung hat
wird zur raum erscheinung das wird dann
schlägt sich dann nieder im bild oder im
text bei der fotografie ist es anders
alles was da ist also die rahmer
erscheinung selbst wird hat bedeutung
dadurch dass sie existiert das heißt die
objekte präsentieren sich praktisch an
uns am subjekt vorbei und es ist auch so
der fotograf die fotografin weiß nicht
um all die details der am ende die am
ende auf dem bild sind ja das sieht man
nicht alles aber es gibt kein einziges
detail in ein bild das in einem gemalten
bild oder in einem text der an subjekt
vorbei dort hinein gelangen könnte
jetzt wollten wir eigentlich primär
beschreiben wir sind schon ins
kritisieren abgerutscht
aber vielleicht nehmen wir einen aspekt
auf der auch wieder beschreiben der
natur ist nämlich die frage was diese
facebook-community eigentlich sein soll
es ist ja so dass eben der herr
gumbrecht betont dass wir in dieser
präsenzkultur zur welt umarmung gelangen
könnten und in dieser welt umarmung kann
man sich auch vorstellen
hat man eben diese ganze facebook
community platz die ja ständig wechseln
und was genau damit gemeint ist dazu
möchte ich gerne ganz kurz mark
zuckerberg zu wort kommen lassen den
gründer von facebook
ganz kurz ein kleiner sozusagen fast
schon witz von ihm zwei milliarden
menschen zu verbinden ist eine
großartige sache in einer community 7
milliarden wären noch besser sind noch
nicht ganz zwei milliarden aber sieben
milliarden hätte er gerne ist es
wirklich eine gemeinschaft was da
zusammenkommt auf facebook ich folge
diesen gedanken ein bisschen in meinem
buch und zwar ausgehend von der
gemeinschaft theorie des französischen
philosophen lang sie der in seinem buch
singular plura sein und auch in anderen
schriften die idee einer gemeinschaft
einer grundlosen gemeinschaft entwickelt
also eine gemeinschaft die keine
gemeinsame substanz hat kann ich gar
nichts teilen die nichts teilt also
nicht die gleiche sprache und die
gleichen werte oder religion oder land
er definiert gemeinschaft also nicht
über oder community nicht über commune
kommunion wo man etwas sich zu etwas
bekennt sondern über kommunikation und
über das das mit dem anderen sein und
und das ist er
das ist die gemeinsamkeit die man teils
also dieser grundloses dieses grundlose
miteinander sein
das stiftet eine gemeinschaft für die es
keinen kein außen mehr gibt aufgrund
eben etwa nicht geteilter werte in der
konsequenz führt das dann allerdings
auch dazu das geschwätz die banalitäten
mit einzubeziehen denn auch sie sind
ausdruck eines mitteilen dass eines des
willens sich mitzuteilen und des mit
science mit dem das mit den anderen sein
wollen und er rechtfertigt auch wirklich
expressis verbis das geschwätz in seiner
theorie
er spricht nicht über facebook texas vor
entstanden und auch in seinen späteren
texten ist er nicht auf facebook
zurückgekommen ich unternehme diesen
versuch das zu verbinden und spiele den
gedanken ein bisschen weiter und frage
die frage ob facebook die praxis zu
dieser theorie sein könnte und mein das
ergebnis ließe sich vielleicht in den
boxen satz zusammenfassen dass facebook
nur die lösung ist wenn nur facebook die
lösung ist das heißt wenn wir uns nur
auf facebook bewegen würden dann wäre
diese banalisierung dieses miteinander
dieses dauerkarten dieses dauer quasseln
oder diese faktische kommunikation
kommunikation um der kommunikation will
und um es nicht so kreativ zu sagen
dann wäre das vielleicht die lösung aber
wir leben ja nicht nur auf facebook wir
leben ja einen realen kontext und wir
stoßen den realen kontexten wir erleben
in realen kontexten interessenskonflikte
erleben ökonomischer und macht
spezifische art und wir erleben
unterschiedliche perspektiven
wertvorstellungen usw
die dann aufeinander treffen und mit
denen wir dann doch umgehen müssen und
darauf bereitet aber facebook gerade
nicht vor weil sie mit facebook und im
internet generell eben nicht diese diese
ironie und dieses dieses den anderen
gelten lassen entwickeln sondern eben
die die wertegemeinschaft der filter
blase etwa haben ein stichwort das jetzt
nach der wahl von kramp sehr in den
medien war und facebook und andere
soziale medien erlauben das leben das
sie dann die schwierigkeit dass wir gar
nicht konfrontiert werden
der realen anderen meinung sondern uns
sowieso immer nur in der filter blase
also in dem was uns zugespielt wird von
algorithmen was uns bestätigt in der
meinung die wir ohnehin schon hatten
dass sie uns nur damit auseinandersetzen
bleiben jedoch gerade bei dieser kritik
auf die wollte ich nämlich auch mit
ihnen zu sprechen kommen tatsächlich ist
facebook ja jetzt aktuell sehr in die
kritik geraten nach der wahl von donald
trump auch schon nach den briten
stückweise
unter dem stichwort fake news hat man
diskutiert das eben facebook dafür
verantwortlich gewesen sei dass ganz
viele falschmeldungen die aber in
seriösem outfits sozusagen daherkommen
im netz kursiert sind und die leute
beeinflusst haben für wie groß halten
sie das problem der fällt muss ich halte
das für ein sehr ernstes problem
mark zuckerbergs erste reaktion war dass
das eine krise adir ist dass die fake
news irgendetwas bewirkt hätten irgend
einen negativen einfluss haben könnten
da es sich nur um ein prozent aller news
auf facebook handelt
wenn sie aber all die safe ist vor dem
eiffelturm und all die katzen fotos und
babyfotos abziehen die sich auf facebook
finden und nur dass die politischen
meldungen nehmen dann wachsen diese 1
prozent sehr schnell zu viel mehr
prozent man hat es gab eine untersuchung
für politisch orientierte
facebook-seiten da hat man festgestellt
dass 19 prozent glaube ich waren es bei
den linksgerichteten seiten die 19
prozent der meldungen waren fix und ist
doppelte ungefähr bei den
rechtsgerichteten seiten und das ist
eine große menge werden sie bedenken
dass sich ein großteil der bevölkerung
40 prozent etwa sagt man seine
politische orientierung bei seinen
politischen informationen auf facebook
holt es ist inzwischen die größte
zeitung der welt
aber das würde im grunde genommen
geheißen dass dieses versprechen von
frühjahr facebook überhaupt das internet
könnte die welt auch zu einer
demokratischeren welt machen ist
vollkommen in die irre gelaufen
ja also man muss es jetzt nicht ganz man
darf natürlich nicht übersehen dass es
möglichkeiten
eine demokratische verständigung gibt
durch das internet die es vorher nicht
gab ja zum pascha sie können sich
jederzeit als einzelner mit anderen
einzelnen die betroffene sind in der
gleichen frage wie sie organisieren über
über ein soziales netzwerk und dann
natürlich auch ihr problem besprechen
und nicht wäre
lesbisch ich möchte gerne eine
regenbogen familie gründen kann ich mich
organisieren aber ich hinterlasse meine
spuren bin eine gläserne bürgerin die
krankenkasse meistern schon mal was mit
mir los ist und so weiter
damit haben sie schon den einen
negativen aspekt gebracht dass man auf
facebook oder einer sozialen netzwerken
insgesamt im internet natürlich dann
gläsern wird dadurch dass man dort
auftritt aber die organisations
möglichkeiten gibt es natürlich die sie
vorher nicht taten wo sie dann
vielleicht mit ihr mit ihrer
orientierung allein in einem
konservativen dorf waren und überhaupt
keine bestätigung durch andere denen es
ähnlich geht wie ihnen hatten und
dadurch eben auch nicht selbst sich
emanzipieren konnten zu dem was sie
fühlten was sie sein sollten
ja das haben sie jetzt natürlich weil
sie die gleichgesinnten finden aber dass
das dieses dieser aspekt dass sie immer
gleichgesinnte finden der ist eben auch
das problem dass dann dazu führt dass
ich mich ein kapseln kann in filter
bubble aber noch einmal zurück auf die
frage wie demokratiefähig das internet
ist die man hat das sehr hoch gelobt
weil das internet das ende der
gatekeeper ist der diskurs polizei
der französische philosoph michel
foucault einmal beschrieb oder der
meinungs- elite die eben bestimmt wer
zugang zur öffentlichkeit hat zum
beispiel im fernsehen oder im radio oder
in den zeitungen
jetzt hat jeder zugang und jeder kann
gehört werden und das ist in der tat ein
vorteil
der nachteil
dabei ist allerdings und das ist
eigentlich eine dialektische bewegung
der nachteil ist dann dass man aber auch
nicht mehr
das ist auch eine eine entthronung der
experten bedeutet und nicht alle
gatekeeper nicht alle meinung nicht alle
experten sind da gleich mit meinungs-
elite zu setzen oder es sind einfach
leute die über etwas besser bescheid
wissen aufgrund ihres hintergrundes und
der langjährigen beschäftigung damit und
deswegen auch gehört werden sollten und
eben auch für qualität sorgen wenn es
zum beispiel um den journalismus geben
wenn sie die entwaffnen oder entthronen
und nun jeder etwas sagen kann dann ist
das eine demokratisierung prinzipiell
erst einmal die aber auch dazu führt
dass sie dass es keine
qualitätskontrolle mehr gibt für das was
kursiert und das ist ein problem das
jetzt deutlicher zu sehen ist als in den
90er jahren wo man das durchaus schon
diskutiert hat aber die euphorie über
die demokratisierung der kommunikation
war damals so groß dass diese stimmen
sich damals kaum gehör verschaffen
konnten das hat sich mit der kritischen
wende in der theoriebildung zu den neuen
medien dann anfang des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts geändert und jetzt mit der
wahl dies auch in den als thema als
bedrohung der gesellschaft an
aber es ist ja auch bedrohlich also mich
persönlich war das betroffen es gab
einen großen artikel im tages anzeiger
das magazin
da wurde berichtet über cambridge
analytiker diese firma von der man sagt
dass sie eben ganz maßgeblich beteiligt
gewesen sei jetzt am sieg von trump das
magazin hat gewisse dinge dann im
nachhinein relativiert was in diesem
artikel steht aber grundsätzlich kann
man sagen man hat herausgefunden dass es
eben firmen gibt die sehr treff genau
aufgrund der likes auf grund dessen was
wir teilen im internet aufgrund unserer
post voraussagen kann was wir für ein
persönlichkeitsprofil wir haben und uns
dann sehr maßgeschneiderte news eben
zuspiel zum teil auch fake nuss was ist
denn persönlich zu tun wie kann ich mich
davor schützen oder die sollen
mich informieren wenn ich das internet
nutzen also es gibt es gab im nachgang
dieser meldungen dann so eine art erste
hilfe ratschläge was man unternehmen
kann und hinweise darauf wie man weg
news oder falsche seiten erkennen kann
zum einen daran dass sie immer
großbuchstaben benutzen oder dass die
url die webadresse falsch ist also nicht
srf punkt ch sondern vielleicht saf
strich online ch ja denn slf funktional
dass das gehört ja dem shf da kann man
ja nichts machen aber strich online
diese url dieser domain name ist noch
nicht vergeben und damit kann man
natürlich dann auch das publikum
täuschen
ein anderer vorschlag ist dass man die
dass man schaut ob bestimmte aussagen
bestimmte meldungen auch von anderen
medien aufgegriffen wurden und gemeldet
wurden wenn das nicht der fall ist dann
handelt es sich wahrscheinlich um eine
lüge oder dass man die umgekehrte google
suche macht also das bild das man dort
findet in google eingibt und guckt ob
das auch woanders auftaucht und wenn
nicht dann ja dann handelt es sich
vielleicht um eine fälschung
also das in erste hilfe maßnahmen die
uns davor schützen können jetzt
falschmeldungen und verführen auf den
leim zu gehen
ich denke insgesamt muss es aber tiefer
ansetzen
also wir müssen wir brauchen eine medien
eine medien bildungsinitiative die
darüber hinaus geht uns mitzuteilen wie
wir effektiv medien einsetzen können für
uns die die auch dann weiter führt zu
fragen wie verändern die medien neue
kulturtechniken die die medien
ermöglichen
wie verändern die unsere kommunikation
und was sind die konsequenzen kann man
etwas dagegen tun und was war es wäre
dann also und fragen sie mich nicht was
man dagegen tun kann
also so allgemein könnte ich das nicht
sagen einzeln müsste man das anschauen
da hätte ich dann schon ihr neues
buchprojekt darüber sprechen wir wenn
ihr buch erschienen ist ich bin gespannt
darauf was sie alles empfehlen werden
ich habe ihn ja gesagt ich bin neu auf
facebook und ich wollte die gelegenheit
nutzen den professor für digitale medien
hier zu haben was soll ich denn nun als
erstes posten auf meiner seite
sie haben gerade einen facebook account
eröffnen haben sie das profil schon
ausgefüllt das hat man schon gemacht das
ist ganz wichtig dann würde ich sagen
als erste meldung natürlich unbedingt im
sinne der selbstwerbung die eher üblich
ist auf facebook schreiben sie doch dass
sie gerade ein erhebendes gespräch über
die abgründe von facebook hatten
und vergessen sie nicht meinen namen mit
einzugeben und natürlich den link dann
zum video
damit jeder darauf klicken kann ok also
eigenwerbung muss sein das habe ich
schon mal gelernt fällt mir ein bisschen
schwer aber machen wir jetzt so link
mache ich später dazu ist gepostet ich
bedanke mich sehr
ich bedanke mich auch für die namen
wunderbar vielen herzlichen dank des
warmen dank für das gespräch
so liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
jetzt sind sie dran
schreiben sie mir auf facebook posten
sie einen kommentar zur heutigen sendung
oder anregungen für künftige sendungen
ich freue mich auf sie nächste woche
plädieren wir entgegen allem zeitgeist
für das nackte wort wolfram eilenberger
spricht mit der preisgekrönten
schriftstellerin sibylle lewitscharoff
über das wunder der menschlichen sprache
in einer entzauberten welt und auch der
film den sie nun gleich sehen setzt auf
das wort
die dokumentation die rede blendet
zurück ins jahr 2009
als barack obama seine erste große rede
im grant park in chicago erhielt der
film fragt welche taten den worten von
damals gefolgt sind genießen sie den
sonntag
und wir beide herz immer noch zu machen
jetzt natürlich noch 111 ii für die
website natürlich sein da brauche ich
jetzt mein
richtiges smartphone weil der ice down
der wird das ja nicht richten können
vielleicht können wir das hier mal
[Musik]